[موسيقى]
الان بعد هذه الجوله التي تعرفتم فيها على
اثنين من اهم منتجات شركه
جاء الدوري للحديث عن التوجه الاستراتيجي
للشركه في المستقبل خاصه في ظل التنافس
العالمي الشديد بين الشركات المصنعه سواء
لطائرات النقل او حتى لطائرات التزود
للوقود في الجو للحديث حول هذا الموضوع
معنا السيد خسيلويس مدير التسويق بشركه
اولا مصر اهلا بك معنا في عسكريتيريا دعنا
نبدا بالحديث عن طائره اي 330 ام ار تي تي
وكذلك اي 400 ام يعني ما هو الاستراتيجيه
وما هو الهدف من ان تقوم شركه ايرباس بدمج
يعني مجال النقل وكذلك مجال التزود
بالوقود في الجو في الطريقتين رغم اختلاف
مهام يعني طبيعه المهام سواء في النقل او
حتى في التزود بالوقود في الجو
ان كان هناك من ميزه علينا ذكرها في
الطائره الحديثه فهي التناغم فالمنتجان
الجديدان يستعرضان مزايا التنوع في حلول
عاليه الاداء ان تحدثنا عن طائره ام ار تي
تي فهي طائره تزويد بالوقود الجويه وكل
الوقود الذي تنقله محمول على جناحي
الطائره ما يترك الطبق السفلي كاملا للشحن
والعلوي لنقل المسافرين ما يعني ان كل
رحله قادره على حمل الوقود والشحن ونقل
المسافرين وهو الامر الاساسي الذي يميز
هذه الطائره والطائره الثانيه اي 4 ام
ايضا مصممه على نفس النحو بحيث تنفذ ثلاث
مهام في ان واحد معا بوسعها ان تسافر
لمسافات قصيره وتهبط على مدارج قصيره
المدى وبوسعها السفر لمسافات طويله وبسرعه
عاليه جدا كما بوسعها التزود بالوقود جوا
ويمكنها ان تحمل خزاني وقود على الجناحين
اضافه الى خزان اخر مركزي وهاتان
الطائرتان مثال حي على التنوع والمرونه
اللذين تتمتع بهما هاتان الطائرتان
من المعروف الان بان هناك تنافس كبير بين
الشركات المصنعه سواء لطائرات النقل او
حتى لطائرات التزود بالوقود في الجو اين
موقع شركه ايرباص من هذا التنافس وكذلك
على الجانب الاخر ما الذي تستطيع ان تقدمه
لا تستطيع الشركات الاخرى ان تقدمه
لعملائها
المساله بسيطه جدا في هذا النموذج من
الطائرات المنافسه في مجال التزود بالوقود
جوا ونقل المسافرين والشحن فالتنافسيه
تكمن في سعه الطائره للوقود والشحن
والركاب فطائره ام ار تي تي قاد قادره على
حمل 111 طن من الوقود وهو رقم يتجاوز
بكثير سعه الطائرات المنافسه 45 طن من
الامتعه وهو رقم اعلى بكثير من منافسين
وحمولتنا من الركاب هي اعلى ايضا اذ تصل
الى ثلاثمائه مسافر وهو يتجاوز قدره
المنافسين الامر ذاته ينطبق على طائره اي
4 ام فهي لديها قدرات فائقه ونحن نفكر في
جمع هذه القدرات التقنيه والاستراتيجيه في
مكان واحد اي جميع المهام السابقه اضافه
الى تنفيذ مهام لمسافات ابعد وتحمل 20
وتقطع اكثر من 30 الف ميل جوي وهو امر لا
تستطيع فعله اي طائره اخرى ناهيك عن انها
تنفذ هذه المهام بسرعه اكبر وعلى ارتفاع
اعلى لدينا كثير من المواصفات الخاصه التي
تضع هذه الطائرات في مرتبه عاليه بين
نظيرتها مصر الدول الان في الشرق الاوسط
تغيرت وباتت لا تسعى فقط الحصول على يعني
انظمه دفاعيه ولكن كذلك تريد ان يكون لها
حصه في مجال انتاج هذه الصناعات الدفاعيه
والعسكريه وبالتالي تبحث عن شركات تشاركها
سواء التكنولوجيا او المعرفه الى اي مدى
شركه ايرباص مستعده لتتشارك في المعرفه
والتكنولوجيا مع دول في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط
هذه المشروعات الضخمه على غرار ام ار تي
تي هي مشروعات تنطوي على تكنولوجيا عاليه
وتستخدم تقنيات متقدمه من مزود
التكنولوجيا لذلك فان هذه المشروعات
تشمل فرصا كبيره للتعاون والتطوير
والانتاج وعندما نفكر بهذه الاصول الضخمه
التي ستبقى بالاجواء على مدى 30 الى 40
سنه سنجد ان هناك فرصا كبيره في الصيانه
والتشغيل لهذه الاصول ما يمكن ان تكون
فرصا جيده للتعاون مع القطاعات المحليه
مسار الخسيلويس مدير التسويق بشركه ايرباس
شكرا جزيلا على هذه التوضيحات